go go sont à pieds joints dans
l'industrie du jeu vidéo et risque de
faire des vagues
et pour y arriver le géant technologique
mise sur du talent ici c'est la
montréalaise jade raymond qui va piloter
le studio de juste à dia la nouvelle
filiale de google inc et jade raymond
prédit une révolution dans l'univers du
jeu vidéo
car avec stade ya pas besoin de console
même pas pour les jeux complexes au
graphique très détaillée par exemple
vous visionnez la bande-annonce d'un jeu
sur youtube suffit de cliquer et vous
pouvez instantanément commencé à jouer
même sur l'ordinateur le moins puissant
sur le marché et de l'ordinateur on peut
passer au téléphone ou encore à la télé
suffit d'être branché à internet en line
pour tester sa plateforme google a
utilisé le jeu assassin's creed
développé à montréal
la direction de google a d'ailleurs tenu
à souligner la contribution des studios
d'ubisoft au québec denis talbot de
radio talbot s'intéresse à l'industrie
du jeu depuis trois décennies
dan aux gogos d'aujourd'hui c'est une
annonce qu'il vient brasser l'industrie
du jeu vidéo comme jamais si google dit
adieu à la console l'entreprise compte
néanmoins vendre ses propres manette
sadia sera lancée cet été au canada on
ignore toujours combien les joueurs
devront payer pour avoir accès au jeu
chose certaine les géants du jeu comme
sony microsoft nintendo devront réagir
les autres gars en ce moment et surtout
les vendeurs de consoles jeux parce
qu'ils en sont dans leurs petits
souliers aujourd'hui à moins que eux
aussi et c'est sur michael travaille sur
une solution semblable car google vient
peut-être d'annoncer le début de la fête
pour les consoles de jeux vidéo tels
qu'on les connaît ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal